>>> MAJOR LEGAL VICTORY FOR
EIGHT CONNECTICUT FAMILIES AND A
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO SUED ALEX
JONES WHY FOR YEARS JONES SPREAD
THE DESPICABLE STORY THAT THE
2012 MASSACRE AT SANDY HOOK
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHERE SIX
ADULTS AND 20 CHIRP WERE KILLED
WAS STAGED.
HERE ARE THE FACES OF VICTIMS,
YOUNG CHILDREN, TEACHERS AND THE
PRINCIPAL.
THEY WERE MURDERED.
WE REMEMBER THEM.
TODAY A JUDGE RULED THAT JONES
IS LIBEL BECAUSE HE REPEATEDLY
REFUSED TO HAND OVER RECORDS.
A JURY WILL DECIDE HOW MUCH HE
HAS TO PAY IN DAMAGES.
IN SEPTEMBER HE WAS DEFAULTED IN
TEXAS FOR FAILING TO TURN OVER
DOCUMENTS IN A SIMILAR CASE.
JOINING US NOW ATTORNEY CHRIS
MADDY WHO REPRESENTS THE
DEFENDANTS IN THE LAWSUIT.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT LIABILITY
BY DEFAULT MEANS?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON,
ANDERSON.
TODAY WHAT THE CONNECTICUT
SUPREME COURT DETERMINED WAS
THAT BECAUSE ALEX JONES HAD
ENGAGED IN A LONG SERIES OF
MISCONDUCT IN DISCOVERY ABUSES
HE PREVENTED THE PLAINTIFFS FROM
GETTING A FAIR HEARING, THE
EVIDENCE AND BECAUSE OF THAT
FORFEITED THE RIGHT TO PRESENT
EVIDENCE IN THE CASE.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM ARE
CONSIDERED PROVEN AND LIABLE
WHICH INCLUDE DEFAMATION,
VIOLATIONS OF CONNECTICUT'S
UNFAIR TRADE ACT, DISTRESS AND
THE QUESTION FOR THE JURY WILL
BE THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
FAMILIES THAT WE'RE HONORED TO
REPRESENT WERE HARMED BY HIS
CONDUCT.
>> HOW CAN YOU ACTUALLY COLLECT
FROM HIM?
DOES HE HAVE ASSETS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THIS CASE IS
NOT REALLY ABOUT MONEY.
IT IS ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND SO OUR GOAL AND WHEN WE GET
IN FRONT OF THAT JURY IS TO SHOW
THEM HOW DEVASTATING HIS CONDUCT
HAS BECOME.
NOW WE HAVE AVENUES TO
INVESTIGATE HIS ASSETS AND HIS
RESOURCES.
BUT WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE GET OUR DAY IN COURT AND
THAT WE EXPOSE ALEBS JONES FOR
WHAT HE IS.
>> JONES AND HIS ATTORNEYS HAD
YEARS TO TURN OVER DOCUMENTS.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHY THEY
JUST CHOSE NOT TO AT ALL?
WAS IT TO DRAG IT OUT LONGER IN
SOME WAY OR ASSUME HE WAS GOING
TO LOSE?
>> I THINK THE COURT MADE THE
POINT TODAY THAT THE EVIDENCE
THAT HE DELIBERATELY WITHHELD
WAS PRECISELY THE EVIDENCE TO
SHOW THAT HE ENGAGES IN
OUTRAGEOUS INFLAMMATORY AND
DISHONEST RHETORIC TO DRIVE
TRAFFIC TO THE WEBSITE TO
BEN
BENEFIT FINANCIALLY.
HE WITHHELD DATA ABOUT THE
COMPANY FINANCES.
PRECISELY THE TYPE OF EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD EXPOSE THE BUSINESS
MODEL AND WHY HE DOES THE THINGS
HE DOES.
WE THINK IT'S A CALCULATED
DETERMINE NATION TO DEFY THE
COURT'S ORDERS AND MADE FALSE
REPRESENTATIONS ABOUT THE
EVIDENCE AND WHEN THE COURT
PREVENTED HIM FROM SUCCEEDING HE
DECLINED TO TURN IT OF.
I THINK HE PREFERRED DEFAULT TO
HAVING THE TRUTH ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS EXPOSED IN COURT.
>> I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
FOR THE FAMILIES IT IS NOT ABOUT
MONEY.
IT IS ABOUT STOPPING THIS PERSON
FROM SAYING THIS AND SHOWING THE
WORLD WHAT A FRAUD HE IS AND
WHAT HE'S BEEN SAYING.
BUT TO STOP HIM FOR PERMANENT
ONE CERTAINLY STOPPING HIM AND
GETTING THE FINANCES WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE HELPFUL IN THAT
REGARD.
IS THERE LAW -- I MEAN, SOMEONE
CAN'T BE FORCED TO PAY -- WHAT
IS THE LAW ALLOWING YOU TO DO?
>> THE FIRST STEP IS TO GET IN
FRONT OF THE JURY AN ENTO GET A
JUDGMENT AND WE EXPECT THAT A
CONNECTICUT JURY IS GOING TO
FIND MR. JONES'S CONDUCT AND THE
HARM CAUSED TO THE FAMILIES TO
BE EXTENSIVE AND WE EXPECT THAT
THAT VERDICT WILL REFLECT THAT.
NOW, WE WILL THEN GO ABOUT
COLLECTING THAT VERDICT.
AND WE HAVE LEGAL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO US TO DO THAT.
IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
DEFENDANTS WHO ARE EXPOSED IN
THIS WAY TO DO THINGS TO HIDE
THEIR ASSETS.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S WHAT MR.
JONES IS DOING BUT WE HAVE
REMEDIES FOR THAT.